21 year old man is accused in the
shooting deaths of eight people
at three georgia spas nearly all of the
victims were asian
but police say race may not have been
his motive
zach summers has an update from atlanta
the suspect who shot and killed eight
people at three atlanta area spas has
told investigators
he wasn't motivated by rays he made
indicate
indicators that he has
some some issues potentially sexual
addiction
and may have frequented some of these
places
in the past 21-year-old robert aaron
long was taken into custody after a
manhunt
police used surveillance footage to
identify him and were able to track his
phone
he does claim that it was not racially
motivated and sees these locations
as something that allows him to to
to go to these places and it's a
temptation for him that he wanted to
eliminate
seven of the victims are women six are
asian crime against any community
is a crime against us all a day later
detectives are still
at two of the crime scenes in atlanta
gathering evidence
and talking to witnesses a woman who
works nearby
says she knew some of the victims i
won't say any names but they're really
nice girls
they just do great massages they do
great massages over here so it's just
unfortunate
these killings come during a wave of
nationwide attacks
targeting asian americans we're not yet
clear about the motive
but i do want to say to our asian
american community that we stand with
you
as a precaution some police departments
around the country have increased
patrols
in predominantly asian communities zach
summers
cbs news atlanta